oh my God the worst gig ever probably
like I've done a million corporates and
I've told the story before but I got
this big gig because Seinfeld shouted me
out and once Seinfeld did I was at the
Mets game he shouted you out at I was
sitting in the St crazy you know it's
crazy he shouted me out whatever and it
didn't do [__] for my career I thought
oh I'll be selling out the next day
didn't make a blip yeah I mean it was
good for me and my mom fingered herself
and all that but other than that it was
uh oh sorry she knows she's done it and
uh yeah so uh what was I saying sorry
your mom's distracting me yeah yeah yeah
so but what it did do was these
corporates hit me up like who's this Wiz
kid that Seinfeld's talking about you
know and so I got hired by all these
giant pharmaceutical Ford motor compan
money money was a good year yeah and I
bombed every single one of them but this
one in particular they bought me a
tuxedo they got me a limo to
Philadelphia in this beautiful Ballroom
it was a drug company it was like the uh
the Oscars for a drugs right for like
pills and fizer and all this [__] and it
was a 3our thing I was supposed to do 15
minutes up top and actually you know
Jimmy kimlin do the award show sure
Ellen degenerous whatever it was Billy
Crystal so I bombed the first 15 minutes
this is like the biggest gig of my life
this how many people are there would you
say roughly huh how many people I don't
know 600 in a ballroom tuxedo that's
like that's the guy who owns routers and
that's the guy who invented the iPhone
Harvey yeah all those guys were there
the whole thing yeah Al Gore it was
crazy oh my God I know and so I got to
do all the you know the best
anti-depressant goes to d da da you know
all the the drugs that sound like black
women's names and
so I'm in The Tuxedo I go up they hate
me already I got to eat dinner with them
too and then they go Mark Norman the
host and I go up there there's a big
Podium and everything and the first 15
minutes I die zero zero and I'm doing
tonight's show like test
great if if you ask Mark to do his a
stuff it's killer [__] oh thanks and
obviously clean and all that so I was
like man this is a tough group but I did
one joke about a a vibrator but it's
very clean it's just I mentioned the
word vibrator once I see a woman get up
in the back uh she walks out I go ah
whatever she's probably menstrating or
miscarriages or whatever it is and then
I go back uh you know to my ACT blah
blah blah bombing whatever then we go
into the award show and I'm bringing up
oh this guy won he comes up says his
little with the trophy I make fun of him
and then they didn't like that so at one
point somebody's given a speech and I
have to I have a moment off to the side
and this lady in a headset's like get
over here get over here she's like you
pissed off the CEO's wife she's Furious
she's chewing him out in the lobby yeah
I don't know what's going to happen but
it ain't pretty and she's kind of crying
a little bit I'm like what is going on
so I go back up there I'm like hey the
award for the best diarrhea pill goes to
this guy so he comes out and then they
bring me that they're like you're fired
he's pissed the co is yelling at me he's
like w how could you say that my wife is
furious you're such a misogynist I'm
like what are you talking about this is
all Tonight Show stuff yeah and he I I
was like I hope for sefel with this he's
like you're you're a disgrace you should
be ashamed of yourself they fired me
they made me return the tuxedo they gave
the stack of cards to some random Indian
guy and he had to host the rest and they
sent me home what did you get paid I had
to fight for it but I got like half the
money the funniest story you got
funniest story in funniest story yeah oh
jeez all right well I had lost my
virginity to a prostitute when I was
16 yeah I don't know if it's a great
story but I was in the French Quarter it
was Y2K remember that that was a big
deal so it was the night before the
Millennium change so everybody was on
edge you know we thought the world was
going to end and all that and I was
walking down Bourbon Street as a
16-year-old boy fresh pubic Care New
Haircut you know and I had my fuboo on I
was looking
good and you know this lady was on the
on the balcony hot older lady kind of
looked like Jennifer Anderson after a
fist fight and uh she had a a leather
jack with no shirt under it this is pre-
interet porn mind you so that was like
we were just like all right we're going
to plant here and just stare at that uh
crazy KO all night and she caught a
staring and she goes why don't you guys
come up we're like oh my God we're
flipping out you know and so we triy to
go in the hotel they said no guests only
you can't go in so we went back we're
like hey we we we can't get in and she
was like I'm coming down down she comes
down she got the leather jacket the
boobs are out it was insane and uh she
goes you kids want to come up and throw
some beads and I was like oh she doesn't
want to [__] us you know we're children
so my friend is like nudging her he's
like it's it's Y2K [__] it take a
risk so I go hey look I don't want to I
don't want to go on a 2000 a virgin and
she goes well I won't let you and that
was it so she brought us upstairs she
told my two friends go on the balcony by
the way she opened the door there's a
guy in a leather jacket and a
Harley-Davidson hat and a white beard
sitting in a chair staring at the door
and he goes which one is it she points
to me and he goes you too on the balcony
so this is like an arrangement they
have I I don't know if that was her
husband her pimp her Grandpa I don't
know what it was but uh yeah we we they
took them on the balcony closed the
doors behind them she hit the the blinds
and
uh she goes uh how do you want to do
this and I go I was so young and stupid
I was a virgin and I go well I'll take
[__] first you
[Applause]
know she goes I don't give [__] and
I said you you [__] kids off the street
but you don't get
[__] she didn't like that
um and she goes no shut up any other
questions and I go are you clean and she
goes do you want to do this or not and I
said I'm sorry and then she went to the
bathroom came out wearing nothing but
socks I was blown away she was super
pretty and all that [__] and she does
the pad on the bed I sit down next to
her and uh she goes why don't you get a
little more comfortable mind you I was
wearing a leather jacket a sweater a
shirt under the sweater jeans and shoes
so I I took off the jacket and
uh she goes do you have a condom I said
yes I pulled out a condom from like the
Reagan Era you know this thing was old
and stretchy and yellow and she was like
hang on she opened a drawer she had Lube
condoms butt plugs sex toys dild those
vibrators I was like oh my God I'm in
way over my head so uh I was too scared
to show her my full package so I just
stuck the dick through the boxer hole
cuz I was
nervous and
uh we had sex for like two hours 2 and 1
half hours the whole thing was insane I
remember she had the worst breath
probably from the guy she blew before me
but uh horrific breath but it was great
it was a great time she taught me a lot
and uh I I got out of there I pulled my
pants up I I felt violated I felt weird
I opened the door my friends fell in
they were drinking out there for hours
so they're like I got sloppy seconds and
I'm like pulling them out of there you
know and uh we went home and I I guess I
got uh I guess I'm a meet to Survivor
because uh you
know I was assaulted I was young I was
16 so she's a pedophile by law you know
but uh she's got to be dead by now you
know that was 20 years ago and she was
at least 58
so so there you go sir uh all right
there yeah I don't know how long that
was but
yeah best night of my life
still that was Betty White
no have you done already storytelling
show I did I bombed I I feel horrible
about it did you really what was the
story I have a it's a great story but it
had no ending and was like all he need
is a good ending just don't worry about
the store have a good ending what's the
story I I had sex with my screenwriting
teacher and uh I worked at a New York
Film Academy and the one of the teachers
there it's a long story but uh basically
my shower didn't work in Crown Heights
so I was I went like a week without
showering I smelled like [__] my boss
said you got to shower you can't come in
and so I was going around asking hold on
hold on one second you literally didn't
shower to the point where people were
like yeah it was bad you got to take a
shower I couldn't do it cuz I was doing
sets at night then I'd wake up you go
get home at 3:00 in the morning you have
to wake up at 700 for work so you know
we on out of there and we had no hot
water we had no electricity in our
apartment every now and then so it was
snowing out it was too cold to take a
cold shower and uh So eventually I put a
[__] pot on the stove I boiled it in
the dark and I was like I'm just going
to take a horse bath in the kitchen get
it over with the lights click on after I
done showering my [__] roommate
cooked stove top stuffing in the in the
pot so now I'm covered in BO and like
spices and [__] and herbs
but it was too late I had to go to work
so I had to run out you smell like I
smell like Thanksgiving so I remember
getting on the train it was the four
train it was all you know I was the only
white guy and black guys were like
standing over like hold on hold on
sniffing me hold on you took a horse
bath with stove to Stu well it was I put
a pot on I filled it with water and
turned out it was dark so I didn't know
it was covered in corn corn nuts and
[__] cornbread so you're you're smell
bad but now you smell even worse now I
smell like a homecooked meal yeah was
brutal so I now I'm desperate I get to
work and I'm covered in this film and I
got like little parsley pieces on me so
I go up to everybody and one lady the
screenwriting teacher Mrs Fritz will
call her I go hey look uh can I shower
your place she goes sure I don't care
and I was like oh my God she was like
kind of cute like 40 40-year-old quirky
weird earrings big beehive kind of thing
hairdo and uh she was like yeah sure
just come over but I'm having a dinner
din party it's at 800 so if you don't
mind getting out of there I was like you
got it whatever so I get there at like
600 I bring a bottle of wine to be nice
I get there she has beautiful apartment
in Brooklyn all like a [__] spread on
the table just crazy setup dishes
glasswar the place mats I'm like oh my
God she's like eight things going on the
stove bubbling I'm like oh my God she's
really doing this so I get in I go hey
look I'll take a shower be out of your
hair no problem she goes sure sure I
have a glass of wine we don't really
know each other I have a glass of wine
we have two glass of wine three glasses
of wine we're talking about life and
love and philosophy we're going at it
and I was like look it's it's 710 I got
to get in that shower she goes all right
all right well are you hungry and I'm
like I guess I'll have a a bowl she made
paa I was like yeah I hav been I've been
eaten good in three weeks I'll take a
bowl of PA so now I'm eating the paa we
have another glass of wine I'm like hey
look lady it's 7:30 I got to get the
hell out of here having a dinner party
at 8 so she's like all right all right
so I get in the shower and I'm hammered
at this point I've had like six glasses
of wine and I remember being in the
shower washing my body be like this is
so nice then I go am I going to [__]
this woman no what are you kidding get
out of here it's [__] you know 20
minutes till people show up so I got out
of the shower now it's like 7:48 you
know I'm like scurrying like all right I
got to go thank you she goes have one
more glass I'm like all right and she's
like let me give you a tour of the
apartment we're walking around her
apartment she's showing me knickknacks
and whatever now we're standing up on
her couch looking at a painting on the
wall and uh we're both looking at we're
like face to face and she goes uh you
know what and I go what's that she goes
I want you to come and my face swear to
God want you to come in my face and I go
all right and now we're just going at it
we're on the floor rolling around
knocking coffee tables over and all this
[__] just [__] and uh she pulled this
string or something and all the Lights
Went Out in her apartment and we're just
going at it and it was night time just
hot dark sex I wake up the next morning
there's blood everywhere she was she was
on her period And I mean I just didn't
notice it because of the dark it was
just [__] beat red crime scene thing
yeah and I had worked the next morning
so I just had to like so I went from
being the cleanest I've ever been to now
I'm covered in uterine lining so I had
to just put on clothes and go go to work
and uh I remember on the way out she was
like don't you tell anybody and I was
like all right I won't and I of course I
told everybody right when I got in but
uh yeah that was it you're not going to
believe this one it was the last week of
senior year so we're just getting crazy
we're about to graduate so we're at this
park having a big keg party just middle
of the day so then is this high school
or this is high school where I'm I went
to a Catholic High School we're in our
uniform we got like a half day so we're
like let's go to the park we've got a
keg we're out there it's like you know
100 of us drinking so my friend pachy
who was like a sophomore his he wasn't
Pakistani his name was like like
penstein Jeff penstein or something we
called him py and he shows up with my
friend dirty
Turk so he was this crazy kid who we let
hang around us he was way younger he was
like 2 feet tall skinny as hell but he
was he was he would do anything you said
like go jump off that building go say a
racial slur in front of that guy like
jackass kind of it was like Jack but he
was Fearless that guy really shined for
a little bit I think his name is steo
yeah and he's still doing pretty good in
and out of boarding school like parents
killed themselves in front of them one
of these kids you know just seen it all
he was up for anything so we we he goes
oh I got to get something oh there's a
house party there's a house party so we
jump on in my car at a convertible we
jump in my car we're going to this house
party we're in our uniforms and
everything and I'm trying it's rush hour
now so I'm trying to get into a a lane
to merge off the highway and I go hey
man can I get in can I get in the guy
goes nope gives me like a hard nope and
I was like [__] this guy so I get in
behind him and I bump him just for the
hell of it we're hammered you know it's
you know it's 5:00 [__] face him I gave
him a little taparoo so he's like in the
mirror like what the [__] going on
here into my car and we're doing like
the you know blow me he had a ponytail
it was a whole thing no offense and I
have a for you so he's like [__] you
I'll kill you whatever and then we're
like oh this guy wants to play so I tap
him again now he puts the car in park he
gets out so now we're like well I guess
this is on you know but there's two of
us I got Packy here py will [__] just
lunge at him like a rat know real quick
take out his knees yeah he just you know
claw his neck so uh he gets out and he
walks past me so I'm kind of like ready
walks past me goes to the back of the
car reads my license plate memorizes it
walks back up slams his fist on my hood
and gets in his car and I was like huh
well that was weird so now trav's kind
of moving a little bit and I'm like [__]
this guy what cop no no no he was he had
like sandals on and shorts he was like a
hippie kind of guy so now I'm like well
that was weird but he's on a cell phone
this is when cell phones were like if
somebody's on a cell phone you noticed
it a big brick and I was like oh that's
weird so now we're on the main streets
and I'm following him but something's up
and then he gets to a green light stops
and I stop by behind him and everybody's
like why isn't this guy going during the
green light there's a bar on the corner
a guy runs out of the bar jumps in my
convertible Jesus Christ crazy he had a
leather jacket on he was just day
drinking at some bar it was [__]
we're
like he's in the back and I'm trying to
drive py yeah py so so I'm driving now
the the the guy in the car peels off
he's like I'm out of here [__] these
guys but my friend will handle this the
excon or whoever that guy is the guy who
Waits at bars for the phone call
so Bill it's for you it's Jeff I've been
waiting for this call for 5 years this
man saved my life back in n and I owe
him one he just P his drink for he goes
put it on my tab [__] he just takes a
drink shoots it and he goes fill another
one I'll be back in
five fingers door slings open cling
cling cling jumps in the back seat pulls
py back there they're having a fist
fight on their knees in the back seat
just like a cartoon so I'm just like
driving looking backwards trying to not
kill myself still driving because we're
on the street the street is moving
so so I'm like ah I'm like trying to do
swings like back here like trying to
help py like doing some backward hammers
you know like like a mom disciplining
her children in the back seat you guys
stop it yes exactly I will turn this car
around exactly take you back to your
creepy bar so this is a man this a guy's
you know balding he's got a leather
jacket on with patches on it and you
know he's got a half a beard this is a
dude beating up kids on a Bea up a kid
but that that [__] mom strength kicks
in where you're just like scare for your
life you know fight or flight so P's
like one of those windmill windmill
windmill windmill and uh so I just
scream I go py push him out push him out
so py gets some kind of demon in him and
he just gets up under the guy and goes
the guy goes over the back seat off the
trunk rolls onto the street and then
like cars by going try not to hit him
somebody runs over his
hand and I'm like ah the guy goes I'm
like oh my God what is happening so we
go to the house party and we're like oh
my God you're not going to we're telling
everybody I got a whole Pow Wow around
the the living room I'm like this crazy
py pushed about it was insane and
Packy's just sitting in the corner
smoking not saying anything he was a
psycho I think he's since died but uh
you should you should have py with you
at all times yeah I think he's dead now
yeah there's no that guy's aive yeah
yeah oh my God he got the H Packy took
that guy's seat at the bar yes yes
exactly that's the only way to get
that wait wait wait so how does the
story end all right so we're at the
party and I had a beeper at the time and
it was one of those douchy clear beepers
where you could see the electronics so
my mom is going like call Mom Mom 911
mom mom dad dad call Mom we love you
what happened you know and I'm like so I
call my mom you know I'm like hello
trying to be sober and she's like the
police are here get the [__] over here I
don't know where you are I don't know
what you did but I got six cops in the
living room I'm feeding up coffee
they're all waiting you're going to jail
come over hung up and I'm like oh my God
py quick get in the
car so I was like oh [__] and here's
this the clinker this is where I got
saved so I go I guess I got to go home
and my friend Jay goes wait if you're
going home you wre of booze you look
like hell swallow a Big Gulp of this and
he handed me a jar of GIF if you put
peanut butter in your mouth you can't
smell booze I didn't know that some guys
keep peanut butter in their glove box
just in case they get pulled over it it
works 100% so uh I was like all right I
put the peanut butter in I drive home
and this cop car is all out in the front
lawn and everything and I go in they're
all sitting there and my mom's like this
is him when he was 14 she showing him
like the scrapbooks he's a good boy yeah
yeah he was a bed wer here's his Monkey
boo and it's a little you know toy with
the eye missing so I go in they're like
son we got to have a long talk with you
you're in deep [__] blah blah blah I'm
like I don't know what you're talking
about and they go well just don't lie to
us and they keep looking in my eye and
they keep going let me smell your breath
I went and they go oh well he smells
like peanut butter peanut butter by any
normal 18-year-old kid peanut butter
midnight full of peanut butter yeah so
the guy goes a guy says you ran over him
with your 71 Brown cutless convertible
and they go outside that's my 71 Brown
cutless convertible they're like well
this checks out and I go I'm going to be
honest with you a guy jumped in my back
seat and we pushed him out and that's
all we knew self-defense and the guy
goes all
right and then I had to go to court with
my dad like two or three times another
case solved by New Orleans fin all right
and that was
it
everything in that year I mean I uh I
banged a chick in a homeless shelter I
was going on the road as much as I could
it was uh wait wait wait go back to the
homeless
shelter crazy story I was uh I met a
girl at a show I got her number we met
up like a week later I went to a bar
called alligator Lounge where you get a
free pizza with every drink so I met up
met up with this girl and she's just
wolfing down these pizza SLI is putting
them down she was like a cute blonde
chick and uh I was like you all right
she's like I got to be honest I'm
homeless and I go what I'm homeless so
uh we started bonding on the homeless
thing and then she told me she's in a
shelter and I'm like oh so we're making
out we're making out and she pulls me
away and goes wouldn't it be crazy if we
went to my shelter and I was like yeah
yeah go back to make it out go back to
make it out pounding booze pounding
booze before I know it we're in a cab on
the way to the shelter and that's a
funny moment by the way being in a cab
to a homeless shelter so we get there
it's way out in Brooklyn Big Stone
building and she's like I just realized
they're not going to let you in it's
pretty regulated you know so uh there's
this guy in the front you have to like
be buzzed into this huge gate big metal
gate that slides open it goes you know
so uh she has this big hobo key to the
shelter it's like a key with a like a
hubc cap on it and uh she's like maybe
you could go in and just act like you
own the place go in with the the key and
just walk right in you won't have to
sign in I was like all right that's
that's good so I go in I go homeless you
know tough riding the rails you know I'm
swinging the key and the guy's like yeah
yeah whatever it's 400 in the morning
and uh she just walks in and goes hey
I'll sign in cuz she's actually there so
they know her so she goes whatever you
do don't get caught I'm on the third
floor it's the women's floor you get
caught on the women's floor you'll go to
jail cuz like you know I can't go up and
rape women bunch of hobos up there you
know and I remember I walked in there
was this big pit it was this big floor
and it was full of people on CS people
in sleeping bags people crying people
screaming people like kind of wrestling
it was it was wild babies crying it was
crazy and I go up to the third floor and
I run to her room and I open the door
swing the door open and it's got two
cots on the wall jail style stains on
the walls just shitty cracked window and
I was like oh my God she comes in like
10 minutes later we have crazy hobo sex
we go at it thank God had a rubber who
knows where she's been and uh the next
morning I had this crazy like beer piss
I had to get out of me like booze piss I
had the big stomach and I was like I got
to pee she's like you can't go to the
bath you'll get caught and I go I got to
go it's an emergency so I get the key I
run to the bathroom I'm peeing and a
girl comes in I'm in the stall a girl
comes in the bathroom like oh [__] so I
have to sit down and pee you know so she
doesn't know I'm a guy and she just
dropping [__] Soup cans in there I
mean this girl next to me hobo [__] and
I just pull my pants up and get the hell
out of there I give her a key back I say
thanks thanks for nothing I run home
that's [__] crazy wild yeah are you a
drug guy or not not a weed guy I can't
do it I'm too [__] up the weed brings
out all the demons it doesn't suppress
them like alcohol what you like Boo ERS
yeah yeah but you don't seem like uh
last you have your Darkness it's from
your childhood I think so yeah I had a
weird childhood how so well let's see uh
my dad got a wild hair up his ass and
bought a mansion dilapidated mansion in
a poor black neighborhood so first of
all the house was [__] we barely had
running water it was you know we'd have
family meetings like all right go [__]
at school don't [__] here we need the
water and then my dad started running
out of money so he he made the back half
of bed and breakfast like old style bed
so my mom's whipping up pancakes at 8:00
a.m. and I'm like can I get one she's
like blow me dick uh eat a eat a bowl of
Cheerios you [__] and so I was like all
right sorry Jesus and so you and you
know they're so my parents are
Workaholics they're checked out you know
they they they were nice people but
they're just like hey we gave birth to
you you figure it out yeah go watch TV
there's no attention yes Dr Drew best
thing to happen to a [__] comic maybe
but boy it's sad don't give them
attention so what doctor did you say so
he said you're uh cuz I was like my mom
didn't react like I have girlfriends
I'll introduce her to my Mom they're
like woo that was tough I like I was
bombing in there I'm like welcome to my
life you [__] [__] Jesus Christ 20
years of that [__] growing up and uh so
I wonder you need laughs from [__]
strangers exactly like ask me a question
just ask me a random question this is my
mom um a random question um where are
you from
what time is it where are we you know
it's just like oh [__] sorry engag yeah
and she's not mean she's just like she's
just got her checked out yeah she's just
like thinking about all I got to pay the
bill I got to water the plants you know
and you're like did you have brothers
and sisters older brother and he's a
genius he's like this you know math
computer wizard and our neighborhood was
so dangerous that he just head into a
computer like as a kid and he just
became like dos and [__] you make
friends in the neighborhood with the
black yeah yeah but then you got into
fights and there was a lot of racial
tension it was the '90s and bikes were
stolen and we got robbed all the time we
had this crazy alarm going off cuz our
house was so big and you would just I'd
be like an 8-year-old kid and you just
hear like glass breaking and
then I'm just like I'm in my room like
hugging up Teddy you know hoping I don't
get raped by [__] Leroy and uh you
know you go downstairs and hey the TV's
gone today you know and that was that
was a Tuesday and we got robbed all the
time my dad he's got like he's like
nword Rich you know he's like we're
going to buy a shitty Lexus but it's a
Lexus you know so the Lexus would get
stolen he's like all right he he give me
like cab money to go to school and [__]
and uh that was just how it was I I
remember I told the story on Rogan but I
got my bike stolen just just Street
toughs you know they would rub their
front tire on your back tire and that me
like oh you're [__] and they would
just take your bike what was the last
when was the last Almost fight you got
in well we got into a rough one in New
Orleans uh you know we were just feral
kids with nothing to do so we' just get
drunk and we' drive around and break
side view mirrors off cars that was like
our Pastime we were pieces of [__] kids
and we hit the wrong car it was one of
those lexuses with the hard top would go
down those sexy sports cars good car
that was a hot car it was right when it
came out and we're like oh we're GNA
knock this one off so you take off your
Doc Martin and my friend just wild back
boom and the the mirror went everywhere
we're all laughing and this guy comes
out of the house big buff Asian dude
with a pony tail in boxers runs out and
it's like a high porch and he comes out
he's like what the [__] and he has like
a Roid Rage runs down the stairs jumps
in the car like a movie ponytail
flailing and we're like let's get the
[__] out of here it was three of us but
this guy was huge Asian guy with a
ponytail you can't [__] with that no so
I'm like drive drive drive I'm in the
back seat was a Jeep Cherokee so not the
fastest car so I know New Orleans I'm
like go up here go one go down this one
way the wrong way he won't follow us he
followed us everywhere and he has a
knife so he's pulling up next to us he's
going [__] cut you and we're we're in
high school we're kids I think they're
called samurai swords keep going yeah
and we're just like oh [__] so I go go
down the causeway the causeway is the
longest bridge in America Theo Von lived
on the end of the causeway that's where
that's how Louisiana Works New Orleans
he lived in Covington which is the end
of the causeway it's like a 26 mile
bridge I was like he won't go on the
causeway we'll just gun it he won't go
it's too far away it's like driving a
you know Staten Island or something so
we're like all right let's go on the
causeway he's going the whole the whole
time pulling up next to us trying to get
in front of us behind us he's just
showing us the knife we're like [__]
this guy won't leave pre-sell phone
everything this is like
1998 and I'm like [__] [__] now we're in
a traffic jam there's a wreck up front
we're in a traffic jam he's about three
cars behind us and we're just like okay
there a bunch of cops up there he's not
going to come up next thing you know
slicing the car up he's like got the
knife on the window he like get out
[__] fight me you [__] come
on fight me ah he's doing this [__]
we're like ah you know we're in our
uniforms and uh he eventually starts
rocking the car kicking the car he kicks
the side view mirror off like a little
payback and uh we're just like freaking
out the cops catch wind to this they see
a crazy Asian guy shirtless slicing up a
car so they tackle his ass they tackled
him and then they're like what happened
we're like we don't know this guy came
after us he's crazy he's he's roid
raging so they [__] Tas him and they
put him in jail and he's like d you have
no idea they come you so he goes to jail
we're like woo we dodged that bullet two
days later we're in high school get
called down to the principal's office
hey you're being sued something's going
on you got to go to court we're like God
damn it so we go back to my buddy's
house we stay up all night make up a
plan we made up a whole story we did a
hear ye hear ye we did a courtroom
reenactment built this whole idea we go
to court two days later we skip school
go to
court Hees doesn't show up and we're
like oh my God we were going to lie I
had this whole scheme plan killed a guy
the night
before so he never showed up so he's
probably in jail for life and
uh I remember I prayed to God the night
before and I was like please don't let
this guy show up so thank God he killed
somebody thank you Jesus for uh I feel
bad for the guy who died but they
dropped it [__] yeah crazy have you ever
done anything with the Trans no I'm not
against it actually I got blown in
Mexico by uh I believe uh I believe a
man I don't ask questions did you sneak
him into the shelter or no no me and my
friends went to Tiana as you do you're
like 18 whatever and they were all
getting [__] and I I was like ah I
don't want to do that that feels weird
Mexican [__] you don't know what's what
and uh eventually I was like you know
what [__] it and I went to this bar and
I got I got blown and I remember the guy
had rock hard tits and I touched his
hair and he was like don't do that cuz
it would move yeah and uh I was like
okay and then I walked out and I was
feeling pretty good and my friends were
all standing outside like you didn't go
in that bar did you like yeah they're
like all busted out laughing so I was a
quiet quiet drive home yeah so you so
you definitely got blown by a trans
woman yeah I think it was just a dude
and and a w
yeah yeah so not even trying yeah but
amazing BJ I mean they know the
equipment it was unbelievable I had
condom on is it better you oh yeah way
better way better they knew she knew
what to do and all that it was amazing
everybody is by you right you're
right you should be able to say all the
jokes then if you've been there oh good
point for real I'll take it N
word I [__] the
uh you
know black guys black ladies very
intimidating I know you like the white
gal the white white C everybody
everybody the uh yeah the black gals
you've been with a few uhhuh nah not yet
not yet hopefully if they're
intimidating why are they intimidating
you just assume the Lakers have been in
there and uh you know just all the giant
giant
men tough follow yes exactly
exactly I'm I don't have a tiny penis
I'm not saying I'm small but I'm not
huge so uh not LeBron yeah I'm no LeBron
I'm more curry but uh I'm Bugsy Bogues
but but I got good vinage I'm all Vin
that's what girls like for sure you
think no ah yeah yeah well I've had so
many bad heckles uh but the one that
really [__] me up was I was doing a I
was kind of new I was probably like
three four years in I got a college gig
which was huge yeah good money fly you
down put you up and I was in Florida and
it was called Florida Atlantic it was an
all black school which I didn't know but
I don't give a [__] yeah so I show up
and I had to follow a rap group it was
like kind of a talent night I had to
follow a rap group and they were like
twirling shirts going kill whitey [__]
the cops I'll kill you you know [__]
this [__] or whatever and they're
killing like the the whole place is
jumping yeah yeah it was the DNC basic
yeah and uh I remember there was like a
little cute nerdy black girl with a
clipboard going okay you're next and I
just want to let you know it's very
diverse like it's not diverse it's all
black I'm the
diversity but whatever so it was me and
this other kid and we were both supposed
to do 30 minutes so so uh you know these
people don't want 30 minutes of one guy
so he goes up first and they trash him
immediately and he gets off after like a
minute and a half and I was like what
are you crazy you got to do your time at
least so he's like [__] this I'm out of
here I'm calling my agent he was like a
he had self-esteem this guy oh yeah yeah
yeah so then I'm like all right and then
they bring me up like oh we got another
live one coming up oh baby and then he's
looking at me like oh this guy's a goner
like I totally set up for failure so I
walk on stage and I'm walking to the mic
the mic is like right where that camera
is and I haven't gotten there yet and
some guy goes look at this [__] kills
kills it's huge laugh so I was like all
right all right I can handle this so I
was in such a New York State of Mind I
was like damn man what if I was actually
gay and he goes no no you are that got
an the Applause break he's getting high
five they're crowd surfing this guy he's
a hero and then I try to do 20 minutes
uh on Uber after that and they I just
ate my lunch for half an hour but I did
my time